for decades joe biden freely admitted
that the roe v wade decision was bad law
and inherently extreme quote i don't
like the supreme court decision on
abortion i think it went too far i don't
think that a woman has the sole right to
say what should happen to her body which
makes sense because you can't create a
baby without a man so why is it not a
man's issue too shut up they screamed
but joe biden has changed his view now
he will say precisely what they tell him
to say and today he attacked the
overturning of roe v wade watch
we have the strongest economy in the
world our inflation rates are lower than
other nations in the world the one thing
that has been destabilizing is the
outrageous behavior of the supreme court
of the united states
on overruling not only roe v wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy we've been a leader in the world
in terms of personal rights and privacy
rights and it is a mistake
in my view for the supreme court to do
what it did
we're a leader in the world in terms of
personal rights unless you criticize joe
biden on the internet in which case the
fbi may wind up at your house but free
speech is no longer a personal right nor
self-defense
so here in brazil it is still a mostly
pro-life country it's still mostly a
christian country but the left here
would very much like to change that
babies are the problem
we spoke to bolsonaro about this we also
talked about his gun policies and how
provably
allowing civilians to protect themselves
has reduced violent crime here it is
what are your opponents views of
christianity oh yeah i scared them
the left left-wing i mean the vast
majority of them are atheists
they do not respect anything
they criticize priests and pastors and
lula himself has said that he will if
elected he will place priests and
pastors and the military in their
rightful place or in the right place in
society
for instance when the u.s supreme court
recently changed its understanding and
ruling on abortion the left wing in
brazil did not like that
we did like the new stance taken by the
us supreme court because we defend life
from its very conception
but not so among the left-wing people in
lula
lula and the left wing they often say
that abortion is a matter of public
health and it is the woman that should
decide
we believe that the life that has been
given to a woman does not belong to the
woman
and that is a stance espoused by our
religion
the federal supreme court chief justice
barossa who favors abortion he himself
stated that is not the right time to
discuss that issue yet
because there are two more positions to
be appointed to the supreme court
he will certainly if elected
he will appoint chief justices that will
support the abortion policy
in colombia for example abortion has
been confirmed by the supreme court
in brazil the supreme court has
interfered a great deal not only in the
legislative
it would be irrelevant to count on those
who are elected in
just as they have legislated on issues
such as homophobia and nepotism which is
of course the policy of employing
members of your own family as a publicly
appointed member of congress we lowered
the tax called ips
the tax on industrialized goods and the
supreme court said that was not correct
they changed it
very often the supreme court in brazil
they make decisions that should
otherwise be only decided by the
executives
such as for example federal taxes
the left in brazil lula seemed to be
trying to introduce identity politics
american-style race resentment-based
politics into brazil
do you notice this and is it working
for
you know even before lula took office in
2003 the left wing would already preach
that i mean the division of people along
identity lines such as blacks and whites
and employers and employees
and people from the northeastern brazil
vis-a-vis
southern brazil they have gained
followers as a result of that approach
and the major divisionary split today is
between employers and employees
lots of followers and they say that hey
you're not doing well today because of
your employer
and that divide approach or policy
the workers probably have always gained
at least one fourth of the brazil
population they have always been
supported by at least one-fourth of the
brazilian population my father-in-law is
known as paulo negon black man and i am
blue-eyed white man
racism is there in brazil yes but not as
it is often described
most of our main football players are
you know people of african descent no
worries
you've liberalized gun laws here you've
made it easier for civilians to own
firearms why did you do that
i was unable to actually change the
brazilian law but by means of a
presidential decree and also through
ministerial orders we interpreted the
existing legislation as best as possible
and there has been a substantial
increase in the number of people who own
legally owned firearms in brazil
and the consequences you see in the
brazilian media is the drop or a drop in
the number of people who are killed by
firearms in brazil
we believe
we understand that once people get armed
you know the crooks the thieves will
think twice before they break into other
people's property
if of course the number had gone up i
would be blamed but just the opposite is
going on today
and if re-elected if everything goes
well
we will have a substantial support in
congress and we will be able to pass
laws on firearms very much along the
same lines as in the u.s
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight